all right are you ready to get started
this is
okay
uh we do have some Replacements uh you
guys can get yeah okay well because
sorry could it just happen yeah so
unfortunately but I think we're all
pretty much
we're good to go okay House Bill 65
represented below moose uh not
recommended for future legislation uh
yes and um the reason is the New
Hampshire DHHS food safety department
has made changes to rules which includes
allergy awareness training for
restaurant employees and I do have a
note an individual who has
life-threatening allergies to some foods
cannot be guaranteed
absolute adherence to the rules due to
staff shortages
perfect any discussion on the motion
uh yeah sure oh yeah oh so they don't
give you the regular cheese
um I would do up here it says
yeah I would just write the name above
it okay right up there
okay
motion clear
the clerk will call the roll
right all right we have some
substitutions today
uh representative potusik
representative bone
clerk votes yes
representative Hamm
representative Doucet yes
representative McDonald yes
representative Johnson yes
representative Bartlett
yeah representative Abel
representative Herbert yes
representative Van Houten yes
representative Fargo
representative Weston
representative bellew
representative Burroughs yes
representative McAleer yes
and uh chairman hunts yes
it says
that is 4 9 10.
16. 16 to zero okay that's my practice
run I'll get better okay just getting
warmed up okay
okay so next up is House Bill 245
relative to the definition of grocery or
convenience stores
okay now let's
I don't know that would be
uh
okay that was supposed to be
representative Terry okay I'll I'll
report out okay yeah
um it's not recommended for future
legislation that is correct uh the
definition of a convenience store is a
store with extended operating hours and
in a convenient location uh stocking a
limited range of household goods
groceries including beer and wine the
Bill's intention was to allow less than
a three thousand dollar inventory of
food items this bill is not recommended
because according to their lobbyists the
store owners do not have an issue with
the three thousand dollar inventory of
food and products the liquor enforcement
and Licensing Division of the liquid
commission agreed to make rule changes
if needed to fine-tune the food product
lists
right and I think that's important I
think that well I would be sponsoring
legislation for next year too to
modernize the language
at least enough to I have to do it for
my wife because she does not like canned
vegetables who does not believe that's a
food product
so we need to clean that up that's a
vegetable
so
okay
so the motion is not recommended
clerk will call the roll
representative petusic yes
representative boehm yes
clerk votes yes
representative Hamm
representative Doucet yes
representative McDonald yes
representative Johnson yes
representative Bartlett
yes
representative Herbert yes
representative Van Houten yes
representative Weston yes
representative bellew
yes
representative Burroughs yes
representative McAleer yes
and chairman hunt yes so that's fifteen
to zero
I think my account was off okay
15-0 so we're missing one two three
okay four fifties up all right
yeah I've been the last count to 15-0
though
uh House Bill 333 relative to the sale
and distribution of Kratom products
representative Herbert moves uh not
recommended for future legislation would
you like to speak to your motion
just that it's been here several times
and it's not really been recommended
okay
[Laughter]
well I'll have you help you out on that
blurb foreign
on my list but but you did okay thank
you we'll we'll clean it up when I get
it so
okay any discussion on the motion seeing
none the clerk will call the roll
okay not recommended uh by
representative Herbert correct
represent batusic yes
representative bone yes
clerk votes yes
representative Hamm
representative Doucet yes representative
McDonald yes
representative Johnson yes
representative Bartlett yes
representative Herbert yes
representative Van Houten yes
representative Weston yes
representative bellew yes
representative Burroughs yes
representative McAleer yes and chairman
hunt yes
15-0
okay on to the next one
uh
I um he's kind of right to he's going to
write I'll write it for you right or you
want to write why you want to write
something then you email that to me okay
and then I'll okay I will fill it in
okay
Mr chair
I just wanted to apologize to the
committee for showing up late I didn't
leave enough time there was a bad
traffic jam on route 101.
I guess that's the nice thing about 202
I don't get too much traffic
okay I'm glad you're here
all right uh House Bill 343 relative to
building for ambulance services I assume
that's representative Weston and moose
not recommended for future legislation
uh we do recommend this for future
legislation we do yes my motion is to
recommend for future legislation and uh
there is considerable need to
um uh to do something about this issue
of reimbursing rural ambulance services
the bill that we have right now does not
fit the bill it's too complex but we do
hope that in next year there will be a
study committee with all the
stakeholders at the table to consider
further legislation to deal with this
issue the issue still exists it has not
gone away no I understand that but but I
think the idea was that the bill in its
current form
is not recommended for future
legislation
so that yes anything that comes that
that uh bill because we'll have other
bills that I I think that I will be
sponsoring bills next year but I'm just
saying we don't recommend this bill in
this term specifically this specific
bill in its current form and its current
form is that all right with you Ania
yes and
um representative ham and I are going to
be working together yeah and putting all
the exactly exactly yeah so it's just
just this bill in its current form but
then in the blurb if you want to write
it or if you want to write it say you're
going to put in legislation for next
year that will uh be light you know that
would try to focus in on on the primary
issue
put it in um this coming year it will be
you were going to do a study you're
right okay you can write that in the
book okay is that okay okay
understanding that situation then I say
it's not recommended for future thank
you
and you can write the book is it is that
all right okay so um
okay uh so that's Burrows
no Burrows she's ready to blurb right so
at this point it's Burrows
that we don't care about yeah
representative Abramson so I I heard you
say this last week but I disagree with
the interpretation of the rules that
when we recommend for future legislation
we're not saying that last year's bill
was was appropriate or well written or
on on any issue
um or that last year's bill was correct
the reason that I voted earlier this
year to hold bills uh for this meeting
was that there was something wrong with
the bill but that there was still an
issue that needed to be dealt with when
I say recommend for future legislation I
I don't mean that a specific exact Bill
the only purpose of this meeting is
whether or not to continue taking that
issue forward and I think that the
balance billing issue is an issue and I
think that future legislation is needed
fair enough okay uh
okay so the motion is not recommended
for future Regis legislation now the
clerk will call the roll
representative petusic yes
representative boehm yes
the clerk votes yes representative
Abramson
representative ham
representative Doucet yes
representative McDonald yes
representative Johnson yes
representative Bartlett
yes
representative Herbert yes
representative Van Houten yes
representative Weston yes
representative bellew yes
representative Burroughs yes
representative McAleer yes
chairman hunt yes 15-1 or is it 16 now
15-15-1 all right
the first the first one I did was off by
one okay
all right moving on uh next up is HB 416
allowing hobby distillation of Liquors
uh representative petusic moves not
recommended for future legislation and
representative recognized to speak to
his motion
um HB 416 uh allowing the hobby
distillation of Liquors the majority of
this committee has voted not to
recommend further action on this matter
according to U.S code the hobby
distillation of alcohol is still
primarily a federal matter
it is therefore a moot point whether or
not the state of New Hampshire permits
it or not it is still a federally
controlled substance
no okay any more discussion on the
motion of not recommended for future
legislation
yes represent just on the principle so I
recall this after we had our meeting
last week just on the principle of when
you have a federal law that says that
you can't do something and then you also
have an overlapping state law that says
that you can't do something if it's our
intent to let the federal government
handle it then we should remove repeal
the state law in my opinion and and
secondly
um
the reason for the other reason for
doing that is
um that the sponsors said that we needed
to have more States send a message that
we didn't want the federal government to
ban hobby distillation of spirits or
whatever the issue is
um I I I see that there's a law in place
and that law should be removed the state
law should be removed because it doesn't
make sense to have both the state and
the federal government duplicating
something it also doesn't make sense to
say that we're just going to wait until
the federal government removes a rule
before we do so because it's it's
another you know year or two years to
get through the legislative process to
repeal some rule perhaps after the
federal government has done so okay so
just everybody remember we actually
passed legislation last year that
lowered the fee that it was required for
someone who was doing a hobby
distillation now notice you could
distill it home all you have to do is
get a federal license A and B you then
pay a new lower from fifteen hundred to
three hundred dollars state license and
you too can distill at home yes
representative Bowen what is your
question or comment thank you yeah I
know I'm a co-sponsor on this bill okay
and
for the last two terms
the thing is it's
what representative Chuck said
it's a federal against it the federal
also says marijuana is illegal yet
we're ignoring that
um so the whole argument about
just because the federal government says
no we have to say no we don't say no on
everything the federal government said
so the point is
is I know a lot some wine and beer
makers that would like to also
do this but not for
sale I mean for personal use and that
kind of thing and and you can go online
and buy distilled distillers I mean they
say for making perfume but we know that
no they actually some of them will say
right out front that is for distilling
all right yeah yeah but so and my whole
thing I knew them study I've said this
on other committees and it really
doesn't matter what we say anybody can
put in the bill one way or another this
just says the last year the interim said
he said to bring this forward and not
bring this forward that's it but anybody
can still bring the bill absolutely
it'll probably representative Wallace
and I will probably still put in a bill
we look forward to seeing it again next
year okay any other discussion on the
motion I'm not recommended for future
legislation seeing on the clerk will
call the roll
representative petusic yes
representative boam yes
clerk votes yes representative Abramson
no
representative ham
representative Doucet yes
representative McDonald yes
representative Johnson yes
representative Terry yeah
representative Bartlett yes
representative Herbert yes
representative Van Houten yes
representative Weston yes
representative bellew yes
representative Burroughs yes
representative McAleer no
and chairman hunt yes so 15 to 2 14 to
two we had a new Arrival
all right take it back
okay
all right moving right along House Bill
488 establishing committee to study the
benefits of allowing New Hampshire
citizens to purchase health insurance
from out of state companies
foreign
representative Bartlett you signed up
for that one bourbon
or did I do do I do that one
that's me okay representative recognize
to speak to our motion okay thanks
let's see this is um establishing
committee to study the benefits of
allowing New Hampshire citizens to
purchase health insurance from
out-of-state companies
um the motion is not recommended for
future legislation this committee
continues to believe that consumers are
better served by purchasing insurance
from companies licensed and regulated by
the New Hampshire insurance department
if if it were just under consumer
protection statutes companies would be
subject to Triple damages and companies
don't want to enter the state under
those statutes
so um that would be my motion okay any
discussion on them
okay you understand you only get to ask
one question per Bill okay yes
representative so the study committee is
obviously only a study committee I
usually vote against study committees
except when this bill was brought up a
few years ago before this committee and
the issue has been brought up of course
before other committees the question was
what was the benefit and of course the
number one issue brought up is cost
savings so the previous insurance
commissioner said that the state might
save 10 percent or consumers might save
10 percent then later seven and then
five
um so the importance of the study
committee is one to figure out what's
the best what's the benefit in terms of
cost savings but the other benefit other
benefits could be easier access to
doctors or medical care or greater
competition or greater quality of
service or greater quality of customer
service or whatnot so I felt that the
study committee was necessary before we
could go forward with other legislation
obviously the New Hampshire Republican
platform says guaranteeing people the
ability to buy health and Insurance
across state lines if they so choose
and for those two reasons I'm voting no
on the motion
represent below I am so tired
tired platform we are working for the
citizens of New Hampshire and not for
the Republican party thank you
um I I would have to
no I'm going to respond and I would say
is we I've asked you in the past to not
bring up party platform issues in the
committee that is something you leave
for the caucus when we're in caucus you
can talk about the platform all you want
but when you're in session where we're
in executive session or the house floor
for that matter either times you do not
mention a party platform issue can I
respond to that
it
take it for what it's worth Max oh okay
take it for what it's worth okay that's
my request I 100 disagree with you and
the reason is many of us
from this term in previous terms when we
campaigned people would ask what are you
for when I go door to door I go door to
door and I campaign and they say well
what are you for and I say I'm a
platform Republican I let people know
before the election this is how I vote
and I vote 85 90 of the time with the
Republican platform I appreciate that
and I want to Let's I don't want to
belabor this okay Max so I've asked you
I just don't agree for the rest of the
day
do not mention the party platform
please thank you
okay
comment
um in respect to everyone here those
people watching and those people of whom
these bills are important I respectfully
request that you keep all of the
comments Salient to the bills beforehand
and any extraneous conversation can
happen outside of this committee thank
you
she's asking me not to do what I just
did so
I okay
moving on uh so uh
so the motion is clear and not
recommended for future legislation the
clerk will call the roll
all right representative petusic yes
representative boom yes
representative Ammon votes yes
representative Abramson no
representative Hamm
representative Doucet
representative McDonald yes
representative Johnson yes
representative Terry
yes
representative Bartlett yes
representative Herbert yes
representative Van Houten yes
representative Weston yes
representative bellew yes
representative Burroughs yes
representative McAleer yes chairman hunt
yes 16-1
okay house pill 592 requiring bond for
pharmaceutical companies providing
vaccines uh so unfortunately
representative Gleason is not here
um but I will so I will make the motion
of not recommended for future
legislation and
um he he will write the blurb when it
when he gets it but the the point being
is that at this point in time this
legislation is really not necessary the
issue is still there but that uh at this
point we don't we don't need this bill
at this point
any other discussion on the motion of
not recommended for future legislation
seeing none the clerk will call the roll
representative petusic yes
representative boehm yes
clerk votes yes representative Abramson
no
representative Hamm
representative Doucet yes representative
McDonald yes
representative Johnson yes
representative Terry yes
representative Bartlett yes
representative Herbert yes
representative Van Houten yes
representative Weston yes
representative bellew yes
representative Burroughs yes
representative McAleer yes
chairman hunt yes 16-1
okay
I'll spill 1019 establishing a committee
to study the replacement of certain
professional licenses with mandatory
minimum liability insurance requirements
uh that's representative Bartlett thank
you Mr chair
um my motion would be not recommended
for future legislation
and are you want to speak to the
question thank you
um an insurance policy does not take the
place of licensing requirements enforced
by the state
um if enacted the insurance company can
deny or cancel coverage insurance
premiums would be much higher if
available at all
etc etc
you said to keep them sure
I will elaborate a little bit more on
that one okay so motion representative
are you going to speak on every one of
these if I'm voting against uh the
majority motion okay go ahead
so I disagree with the majority of
motion um I believe that the issue is
worthy of study and the reason is is
something that the chairman brought up
last week that anything under the
consumer protection act and almost
anything in general that we handle
through our courts people need to have
recourse there are lots of Professional
Licensing 30 percent of workers now have
to get a state professional license
um it can be an onerous process
um but my other concern was for
consumers
um that uh consumers if someone has a
state license but they don't have uh
business insurance they don't have an
insurance policy available you have no
one to go after
um and I felt that from the consumer's
Vantage Point looking at one piece of
paper versus different piece of paper
um
to make sure that someone is actually uh
able to do the job I felt that the
insurance companies
um in my experience have had a tendency
especially if they're carrying heavy
policy to do due diligence and make sure
that not only do people
show that they have the skills but also
maintain them do random inspections and
whatnot on equipment so I felt that the
bill was worth study or the issue was
worth studying
okay
the motion is not recommended for future
legislation a clerk will call the role
representative batusic
uh yes representative boom yes
representative Amendment votes yes
representative Amerson no
representative Hamm
representative Doucet yes representative
McDonald yes
representative Johnson yes
representative Terry yes
representative Bartlett yes
representative Herbert yes
representative Van Houten yes
representative Weston yes
representative bellew yes
representative Burroughs yes
representative McAleer yes and chairman
hunt
yes 16-1
okay House Bill 1028 relative to the
form of individual health insurance
policies
I assume this is yours representative
Barlow yep thank you
moves moves not recommended for future
legislation and is recognized to speak
to her motion
um thank you Mr chair
individual policies with abbreviated
coverage
um these are the types of of policies
that are available these are also I
believe for small group as I remember
the was it just individual it's an
individual it's just individual okay
um I haven't gone back into my notes
um
they cannot meet the federal
requirements and still be profitable
insurance department has opposed it and
therefore
I don't recommend it
okay any more discussion on the motion
of not recommended for future
legislation
seeing none the clerk will call the roll
representative petusic yes
representative Bowman yes
clerk votes yes representative Abramson
no
representative Hamm
ER representative Doucet yes
representative McDonald yes
representative Johnson yes
representative Terry yes
representative Bartlett yes
representative Abel
not here oh sorry I forgot the cross
though
representative Herbert yes
representative Van Houten yes
representative Weston yes representative
bill you yes
representative Burroughs yes
representative McAleer yes
and Sherman Hunt yes
uh 16-1
okay
uh House Bill 1162 relative requiring
insurance coverage for vaccinations
devices and medications authorized for
emergency use by the United States Food
and Drug Administration
uh this is another bill that uh
representative greeson was going to
carry so I will carry forward
um not recommending for future
legislation
is there any discussion on the motion
are you are you on that one I'm sorry oh
I take it back all right yes
representative right um yeah it's not
recommended for future legislation
because there is insurance coverage
according to the New Hampshire insurance
department uh you can find that
information on the legal information
page docket number 20-016-ap
um that's it okay any more discussion on
the motion
see none the clerk will call the roll
representative batusic
representative Bohm yes
Workforce yes representative Everson aye
representative ham
representative Doucet yes representative
McDonald yes
representative Johnson yes
representative Terry yes
representative Bartlett yes
representative Herbert yes
representative Van Houten yes
representative Weston yes representative
bellew
representative Burroughs yes
representative McAleer yes
chairman hunt yes
17-0 okay
all right uh next up House Bill 1245
relative co-payments for services
rendered by a chiropractor
okay representative Bartlett recommends
not recommend for future legislation
Bartlett is recognized to speak to her
motion thank you Mr chair
um we heard testimony on this um that
went on for quite a while during the
public hearing
and one of the things we had to always
keep in mind is that the more the
insurance companies are required to pay
the higher the premiums are going to be
the this bill would like chiropractor
chiropractic service to be treated as
Primary Care
and it was noted that few would go to
the primary care physician as often as
they are likely to go to a chiropractor
um so uh our the committee's feeling has
been that we continue to leave
Chiropractic as a specialty with a
different copay if insurance carriers
want to treat it that way
any more discussion
seeing none the clerk will call the role
I'm not recommended for future
legislation
representative petusic yes
representative Bohm yes representative
Hammond votes yes representative
Abramson aye
representative ham
representative Doucet yes representative
McDonald yes representative Johnson yes
representative Terry yes
representative Bartlett
yes
representative Herbert yes
representative Van Houten yes
representative Weston yes
representative bill you yes
representative Burroughs yes
representative McAleer yes
chairman hunt yes 17-0
okay
all right
next up uh House Bill 1378 relative to
inspection of public lodging houses
uh this was another one representative
greeson I would say is uh
he he wanted to recommend for further
legislation
um and but I'm going to again be
consistent that I'm not recommending
this bill for for future legislation
however I am working on an amendment of
a bill for next session to really drive
down at this issue because uh it comes
down to is really is the hotel has to
have a policy on whether what they're
going to do the employee should not be
the one who has to make a decision yes
or no whether you're going to show it
let alone the fact the language is very
archaic because they're I'm pretty sure
no Hotel out there actually still has
the book in which you sign in on I think
it's a privacy problem right now the
get-go uh that uh that we don't have
that anymore I I remember in past years
looking at hotel when I thought somebody
was at the Eugene McCarthy was at the
same Hotel I was at I remember this is
years ago and I went back looking at the
book and to see if his name is signed in
so in any way I would say say that this
bill is not recommended for you to
legislation but this issue will be back
next year
any discussion on the motion
representative abenson
um so I felt that this was not only a
fourth amendment issue but so I disagree
with the your motion um I think that the
bill is fine as written
and the the statute actually says that
all Hotel Keepers and all persons
keeping public lodging and so on shall
keep a book or card system and cause
each guest to sign in their own legal
name so that that mandate is still there
adding to that uh
the fact that there was potential for
abuse
um I asked about that question and got
only an insurance from the witness that
that she would hope that it that this
power wouldn't be abused
um so we asked whether or not say a
sheriff's deputy or an officer should
simply have to call in a warrant which
only takes a couple of minutes
to uh to do that I felt that that that
was a a right and proper that
um that that's a simple due process a
constitutional step that the that that
uh that are a login like this would be
the the property of the hotel owner of
the property owner and
um
that when I did ask people their opinion
on social media when I asked my
constituents uh person to person they
seem to agree that it is a fourth
amendment issue
um and and of course the other issue
that was brought up by some members of
the committee that potentially you might
have
um an abusive spouse or boyfriend or
some such thing going in and misusing
this power to track it on their say
their ex-girlfriend or ex-boyfriend and
we felt uh some of us expressed concern
that if there isn't some kind of written
record if there isn't some type of uh
search warrant or something that's
that's been logged somewhere that
there's no way to uh deter the misuse of
this power
any more discussion on the motion oh
representative Terry yes on the basis uh
Mr chairman on the basis of your
representations to the committee that
you intend to
um lean in the directions of sympathy of
the concern expressed in this bill and
given the fact that it will only be
several months before you uh file your
Amendment although I am in sympathy of
course with representative Gleason as
you know and some of the concerns
expressed by representative Abramson I
will vote Yes on this motion thank you
okay any other discussion on the motion
of not recommending for future
legislation see none the clerk will call
the roll oh just oh I'm sorry
Representative no I would say that I
concur with representative Terry
um I have some concerns as well but
again I think this bill needs to be
Rewritten with those concerns thank you
okay thank you all right and the motion
is made by but by me
all right calling the roll
representative potusik
representative Bowman yes
clerk votes yes representative Abramson
no
representative Hamm yes representative
Doucet yes representative McDonald yes
representative Johnson yes
representative Terry yes
representative Bartlett yes
representative Herbert yes
representative Van Houten yes
representative Weston yes representative
bellew yes
representative Burroughs yes
representative McAleer yes
and chairman hunt yes 16-1
okay uh House Bill 1501 relative to
insurance coverage for Pediatric
autoimmune
Neuropsychiatric disorders
and
representative Herbert
foreign
yes it's uh it's already been taken care
of according to the insurance company
they do insure it but it's very rare and
uh we don't need to pass a bill
so the bill was to push out the
effective date the the department
continuing to monitor it and at this
point the sunset is far enough out that
we don't need to take this issue up at
this time
any other discussion on the motion of uh
not recommended for future legislation
seeing none the clerk will call the
Roman and that is also made by you Mr
yeah yeah that's fine it's me
I have a feeling getting a blurb out of
you might be a little
a little too no you so you're ready to
write a blurb you know you okay
I can do it today okay perfect
representative Herbert
all right calling the roll not
recommended uh representative petusic
yes
presented bone yes
clerk votes yes representative Abramson
aye
representative Hamm
representative De Palma
nice idea
do set yes
representative McDonald yes
representative Johnson yes
representative Terry yes
representative Bartlett yes
representative Herbert yes
representative Van Houten yes
representative Weston yes
representative bill you
representative Burroughs yes
representative McAleer yes and chairman
hunt yes 17-0
okay uh HP 1502 relative to digital
assets and digital Securities
representative Ammon moves not
recommended for future legislation and
he's recognized to speak to his motion
thank you Mr chair so if you recall
House Bill 1502 was rolled into house
bill 1503 and there will be future
arrest legislation that has to do with
uh the UCC code article 12 minor updates
to bring us up to speed and uh we're the
first state to adopt the Full Slate of
uh that article so
this bill was not recommended for future
legislation
okay and any questions discussion seeing
none the clerk will call the roll uh not
recommended
representative petusic yes
representative Bohm yes
clerk votes yes representative Abramson
aye
representative Hamm
representative Doucet yes representative
McDonald yes
representative Johnson yes
representative Terry yes
representative Bartlett yes
representative Abel
I'm sorry not here representative
Herbert
representative Van Houten yes
representative Weston yes
representative bill you yes
representative Burroughs yes
representative McAleer yes and chairman
hunt yes 17-0
yeah
all right I'll spill 1556 relative to
on-premise and off-premise sales at a
beverage manufacturer's facility
representative batusic recommends uh not
recommend for future legislation and
will speak to his motion thank you Mr
chair uh relative to on-premise and
off-premise sales at a better
manufactured facility
uh with cash register technology
available in the 21st century this bill
is not needed
okay
any discussion on the motion of not
recommending for future legislation
see none the clerk will call the roll
representative petusic
representative Bohm yes representative
amendments yes representative Abramson
no
representative Hamm yes
representative Doucet yes representative
McDonald yes representative Johnson yes
representative Terry yes
representative Bartlett yes
representative Herbert
representative Van Houten yes
representative Weston yes representative
bill you yes representative Burroughs
yes representative McAleer yes chairman
hunt yes 16-1 yeah
so just a reminder on this bill is that
the department actually corrected the
rule to make sure that there was not an
issue
okay uh House Bill 1582 repealing the
granite state Paid Family Leave plan
Bartlett representative Bartlett uh not
recommended for future legislation and
representative Bartlett is recognized to
speak to our motion thank you Mr chair
Commissioners Bettencourt and laborers
came to testify last week when we got um
talking about this because they brought
up some updated information MetLife has
offered a proposal and submitted rates
and that have been approved to become
effective one one of 23. they would like
to see the program move forward it is
voluntary there it will run for five
years with an option with MetLife with
an option to request an additional two
years after that period
and so I am not going to but my motion
is to
um not recommend that this bill go
forward
any discussion with the committee
yeah Mike October 7th to the 20th in the
New Hampshire Business Review uh there's
an article about the ins and outs of the
state's family Paid Family Leave plan
how the State's new voluntary program
works I think it's very informational if
I can just put that in the folder that
would be great yes no I have seen that
article and it was a good article
Okay click we'll call the roll on not
recommended for future legislation
representative yes representative Bohm
yeah
clerk votes yes representative Abramson
aye
representative Hamm yes representative
Doucet yes representative McDonald yes
representative Johnson yes
representative Terry yes
representative Bartlett yes
representative Herbert
yes representative Van Houten yes
representative Weston yes representative
bill you yes representative Burroughs
yes representative McAleer yes
chairman hunt yes 17-0
okay House Bill 1589 prohibiting the
sale of products containing
intentionally added pfas representative
M and mood said we'd not recommend for
future legislation and recommended
amendment is recognized to speak to his
motion
oh thank you Mr chair
um the state of Maine is my
understanding has attempted to do this
and ran into some problems so that could
be one reason to wait and also there are
many products that have pfas in them
that this could have unintentional
consequences of banning uh necessary
products that people use so with those
two reasons I recommend
not for future legislation
representative Amerson representative
Bartlett had her hand it before I did
okay representative Bartlett thank you
representative
um
last week after we had our discussion on
this one um Kathy block from the Des
Department of Environmental Services
came over to me and said that she wanted
to make sure that there was something
put in the file saying that the
Department of Environmental Services is
very aware of this situation they have a
new numerous
efforts going into Commission
right and a commission that's right
um already in play I think there's two
commissions actually in place talking
about this issue
um but if we put something in the blurb
so that any sponsor
um who might come forward in the future
knows that there is work going on on
this one this particular sponsor
um didn't even in the public hearing
didn't really realize how very
complicated an issue it is and was not
aware of the study Commissions in place
so um I will be supporting the motion
okay
and you'll you'll put that in here yeah
that's new information to me but I'd
happily put it into the board yeah I was
going to make sure it was in so
representative Abramson um so it's
something of parliamentary inquiry of
the chair um we're saying on some of
these bills we're not going to do
anything just the first year but we'll
wait and see what response we get back
from state agency or the federal
government when we're saying to
recommend or not recommend are we saying
that this only applies for the first
year and we're going to wait and then
next year somebody might put in a
different bill of new information comes
up or is it for the whole session
um as you know
um no legislature can bind a future
legislature so this vote is only saying
that at this moment this bill as it's
written was not appropriate for future
legislation that's all it says it does
not bind anybody from not putting in
legislation come
when at the two weeks after or ten days
after our election in November where we
have a window of opportunity to put a
new bill in so someone could put in the
exact same bill
someone could put in something different
but if this is kind of an asking we're
saying
we've already discussed in its current
form
just as it's written that's all I'm all
we are saying here is this bill written
this way it could be written differently
and have a totally different vote but
it's it's not the specific language or
even the issue right now what we're
saying is right now unless conditions
change at the federal level something
changes in the market something changes
in the way we we view things or
something changes from uh different
information with state regulatory agency
or an ongoing uh civil or criminal case
we're saying based on current conditions
we're not recommending something but if
things change we might change our minds
based on a changing conditions we're
saying at this moment
not any time in the future
we have we're not we cannot have any
control over the future
at this moment
this bill written in this form
this current bill
is not recommended for future
legislation
it's all we're doing
okay
clerk will call the roll uh not
recommended for future legislation
representative petusic yes
representative Bohm yes
clerk votes yes representative Abramson
aye
representative Hamm yes representative
Doucet yes representative McDonald yes
representative Johnson yes
representative Terry yes representative
Bartlett yes representative Herbert yeah
representative Van Houten yes
representative Weston yes
representative bellew
representative Burroughs yes
representative McAleer yes
chairman hunt yes 17-0
and I no representative Van Halen would
not want me to do this but I just wanted
to know the the NPR story The New
Hampshire NPR story today
I found incredibly enlightening because
now I finally realize you know how this
is getting around and it's sludge from
the Our Town septic or Sound Town uh
septic whatever you call it systems
several years ago regarding sludge and
prohibiting the spread of sludge on
farms lodge on farmlands and here you go
10 15 years later there's a problem see
you had such insight
okay House Bill 1591 eliminating the
enforcement division of the Liquor
Commission
uh
is that yours is that yours okay
representative petusic
microphone
[Music]
what did you do to it usually I speak
louder unless everybody can hear me
yeah this is so people at home can hear
you oh okay
uh HP
2022-1591 FN
majority of this committee has voted not
to recommend further action on this
matter the committee believes that this
division is Paramount to the ongoing
enforcement and education efforts of the
New Hampshire Liquor Commission and that
removing or diverting these efforts
would be detrimental to the ongoing
education of our youth about drug and
alcohol abuse and use
to the edge also the education and
enforcement of alcohol laws within the
adult provider and consumer communities
thank you
okay any other representative Abramson
um I agree with the motion uh but uh I
would like to add even further that
um just as some members of the finance
committee told us just removing a
division or removing an enforcement arm
doesn't uh change anything it would just
it would the the rules are still there
the regulations are still there the laws
are still there and you would still have
to have those laws be enforced but if
you're going to have this enforced
as kind of a patchwork in some towns by
town the town police and some the code
enforcement officer in some cases the
county attorney's office trying to
enforce this you'd have inconsistent
enforcement of those rules so if if
there are people out there who were
saying that they wanted to get rid of
the enforcement division maybe they
should be uh targeting the statutes
themselves
fair enough
yes I agree with representative Abramson
I'd rather have a coordinated effort
than a Helter Skelter
uh enforcement thank you
okay
uh the clerk will call the role and not
recommended for future legislation
representative batusic yes
representative Bohm yes
clerk votes yes representative Abramson
aye
representative Hamm yes representative
Doucet yes representative McDonald yes
representative Johnson
yes
representative Terry
yes representative Bartlett yes
representative Herbert yes
representative Van Houten yes
representative Weston yes representative
bellew yes
representative Burroughs yes
representative McAleer yes chairman hunt
yes 17-0
okay great next up 15.95 relative to
establishing a Statewide food truck
license represented below
not recommended for future legislation
thank you Mr chair uh food truck
operators owners operating in these
following cities with health departments
shall obtain a city food truck license
Bedford Berlin Concord Dairy Dover
Exeter Keene Manchester Merrimack
Nashville Portsmouth Rochester and Salem
this is an example of local control
the state food truck license shall apply
to food truck owners operating in all
other towns note a food truck owner
licensed by the state may purchase a two
day operating license in cities for a
fee for events
okay any more discussion on the motion
representative Abramson
um so I I agree that there were problems
and issues with the bill but I I support
with the bill sponsors we're trying to
do and my thought was what would happen
if you had a code enforcement officer
going to a food truck and the food truck
owner wanted to just obtain a state
license because they needed to move from
town to town for their particular
business I'm obviously thinking since I
represent the Seacoast I'm obviously
thinking of food truck operators that
that especially during the busy summer
season would tend to move to different
parts of the Seacoast
um depending on what the traffic is and
what the conditions are and I felt that
having a food truck operator have to get
a license different type of license from
any different towns uh didn't make sense
if there was the option to have them
just get a state license and just and
just take the take the test and have the
inspections done uh kind of once and for
all
good I just want to add to that
my daughter has a food truck in um
in the um in um
in Rye and she does have a state food
truck license and she's there for the
season so many operators that operate
food trucks are in the same area
um most of the season to make you know
the most money
um that they can into that area
not that I want to confuse us anymore
but my understanding was even in all
those communities they still require you
to have a state license state license so
everyone everybody out there has the
state license what this bill would have
said was that no town could regulate it
because
of someone already having that state
license so it was having the state Trump
local control
okay
House Bill 1595 relative to established
you know which we just did that okay all
right so
sorry okay uh the clerk will call the
roll
all right house bill 1595 59 right not
recommended
uh representative petusic yes
representative boom yes the clerk votes
yes representative Abramson no
representative Hamm yes representative
Doucet yes representative McDonald yes
representative Johnson yes
representative Terry yes representative
Bartlett yes representative Herbert yeah
representative yes
representative Weston yes representative
bill you
representative Burroughs yes
representative McAleer yes
chairman hunt yes 16-1
all right Senate bills
Senate Bill 68 requiring employer to
provide reasonable accommodations for
pregnant employees
foreign
Johnson
representative Johnson uh not
recommended for future legislation
because the way the bill is written in
its form is it implies that a pregnant
employee could come or go as they please
rather than the current law which is
that when you're taking time off you
that's it's it that's the clock you know
that you can't that uh even though there
was a lot of discussion about just being
reasonable in terms of a stool or some
seating arrangement but there was no
evidence in which that actually had
occurred that any employer said no he
wouldn't do those kind of accommodations
the heart of the bill was the
requirement that the current law which
is that when a pregnant employee is
ready to take her leave she takes it and
she can't come back until after the baby
is done
or babies
[Laughter]
it was just a recipe
what's up
the event is over how's that okay
until the birth okay any discussion on
the motion of not recommended for future
legislation representative Bartlett
thank you Mr chair
um I would have to say that I'm going to
oppose this
um motion
um the I do feel that we need to have
something codified that does say they
need to have accommodations because
I mean we're still talking about a small
number of workers
not everybody's pregnant very often
then occasionally something does need to
be done and I do think this bill has
Merit and should move forward okay
you know the discussion of the motion
representative Evenson so I thought that
the issue itself did have Merit did
warrant a study committee if another
member was thinking of bringing it
Forward although I usually don't support
study committees
um uh the reason that I felt that the
issue was worth some type of action or
at least some investigation on our part
was obviously for the health of the
unborn baby and for the the mother that
uh when
um uh pregnant mother is put under a lot
of stress physical stress emotional
stress work related stress for a long
period of time they can have long-term
consequences I also didn't agree with
the way that the bill was written but I
supported the idea of at least keeping
the the bill alive and keeping the idea
alive
um to maybe brainstorm and come up with
uh some way to encourage employers to
provide better accommodations
so just to remind you this vote today is
not telling you the plus and minority of
the issue
it is is this bill as it's written it
recommended for future legislation
that's what you're voting on
okay clerk will call the roll
representative petusic yes
yes representative Bohm yes
clerk votes yes representative Abramson
aye
representative Hamm yes
representative Doucet yes
representative McDonald yes
representative Johnson yes
representative Terry yes
representative Bartlett no
representative Herbert no
representative Van Houten no
representative Weston no
representative bill you no
representative Burroughs no
representative McAleer no and chairman
home yes
so I have ten to seven
and to seven
ten to seven ten to seven right and can
the minority
um chime in no
that's afraid of
them no Minority Report
okay
uh but I I will make sure the Minority
Report
recognizes the is the concerns that you
have
yeah
okay Senate Bill 121 relative to
state-based health Exchange
yeah
representative Bartlett
not recommended for future legislation
thank you Mr chair
um many issues with this bill
um that the bill cannot does not and
cannot address
um perhaps uh there was discussion that
perhaps a study committee could address
some of them in the future the New
Hampshire insurance department would
administer this and
um therefore I'm
not recommending this bill for future
legislation
any discussion from the committee
see none the clerk will call the role
representative petusic yes
representative Baum yes
clerk votes yes representative Abramson
aye representative Hamm yes
representative Doucet yes representative
McDonald yes
representative Johnson yes
representative Terry yes
representative Bartlett yes
representative Herbert yes
representative Van Houten yes
representative Weston yes
representative bill you yes
representative Burroughs yes
representative McAleer yes
in Sherman home yes 17-0
okay Senate Bill 287 relative to balance
billing for certain Health Care Services
representative Bartlett
not recommended for future legislation
I just gotta find my I did these on the
order that we did last week yeah I know
I did the same thing okay um relative
balance billing not recommend my motion
is not recommended
um in the New Hampshire Insurance
Department's legal
I don't remember what her title is like
my
um Michelle Egan
um said that this this was the national
no surprises act and it's been put in
New Hampshire law the dispute resolution
issues have been redone by the feds
um and
the department opposes this bill as
written
no the department supported this bill
well the changes were made that were
necessary so it's not enough
needed to be perfectly I mean nobody
here but they they said yeah this is
fine but uh the concern is that now we
have two different statutes and their
argument was that New Hampshire citizens
would be better served if the uh the
the issue of of the what is the fee
that's going to be reimbursed if it was
ever contested which none of them ever
have never been departments never had to
deal with it since it's been in law now
for what two years uh but that uh that
they would be your be more expeditious
if you did it in the state level rather
than under the federal statute and so
they were making an argument for their
you know some I guess the specific
territorial issue but I think they still
opposed what the bill said no they loved
this bill they loved this because they
because this bill was saying because
they were going to give them the power
to okay sorry to get mixed up on that
one of my notes that's why
but in the spirit of being fair I have
to I have to be honest yeah that's fine
okay any other discussion on any
um not recommended for future
legislation
seeing on the clerk will call the role
representative petusic yes
representative boom yes Clark votes yes
representative Abramson aye
representative Hamm yes
representative Doucet yes representative
McDonald yes representative Johnson yes
representative Terry yes representative
Bartlett yes
representative Herbert yes
representative Van Houten yes
representative Weston yes representative
bellew yes
representative Burroughs yes
representative McAleer yes and chairman
hunt yes 17-0
okay
um
so over the last but not least here yep
okay uh Senate Bill 355 requiring Online
Marketplace to disclose certain
information to Consumers
and
what do we have
representative
uh
anybody want to do this otherwise I'll
do it anybody I have representative to
make a motion on this one
yeah
uh I don't have that on my notes but um
I
move forward with this legislation okay
well then we don't want your motion then
[Laughter]
representative hunt Okay
um
well given that that the new person
involved who brought who worked for the
retail Merchants Association
brought in something that was about
Facebook Marketplace in which the
sponsor when she showed up and heard
that that's what he did was was livid
because she knew full well this
legislation would not have one iota
effect on the marketplace on Facebook
Marketplace so clearly the bill and as
in its current form as problematic
because it's in the consumer protection
statute and it's not a consumer
protection issue it is a criminal action
that there is criminal activity going on
it's in the wrong statute and I urge the
sponsor that to bring this bill by
assuming she's going to bring it back
again next year to
put it in a different statue put it in a
different RSA a different place that
where it truly reflects what she was
intending to the bill to do
so it was a statute that was the problem
that fundamentally the statue is the
problem but enforceability seemed insane
and seemed impossible and it it's it's I
know that we had to feel good build but
you know certainly we had testimony from
um an Assistant Attorney General that
showed that it was going to be a problem
he made it clear that enforceability
would be extremely important so are you
again again why it reinforces the
argument it should be out of that
statute it should not be in the consumer
protection statute that it should be in
the criminal statute if they're gonna if
they're gonna go forward with it at all
but again forcibility across state lines
that's a pretty complicated issue yeah
okay okay
yes representative Terry Mr chair as if
we needed more let me remind
uh all of us that there was also an
issue with the dollar limits that there
was a threshold and the threshold was
set
high so high that there would be people
who would Escape
responsibility under the statute because
of the of the dollar threshold limits so
there's also had to be 200. there's a
lot of work that really needs 200
transactions 200 transactions so there's
a lot of work that needs to be done on
this it needs to be completely reworked
okay got it and there is federal
legislation uh that is modeled you know
that they're working on and they keep
hoping that it was going to pass but for
some reason it got put off so
yes representative Abington
so uh I I do support the bill I just
support the concept although I recognize
that um
there's there's a dispute under whether
or not it should be handled on the
consumer protection act
um because this would allow people to
have recourse through both civil and
Criminal Courts I would say that I'm not
going to object to it being under the
consumer protection act
um but I will re-emphasize that the the
the problem of organized crime and I
mean very well organized the problem of
shoplifting the problem of having items
that are specifically targeted by it by
a group that this that this is a major
International issue as a matter of fact
a lot of our our products get taken out
of retail stores and then shipped
overseas
um they're they're very large organized
groups that are doing this
um I have no no question in my mind that
they'll eventually find some way to get
out of this but if if
um
the retail sector is is Big the we had
uh representatives of uh retail coming
in and saying that they needed this
their over 20 states where it's passed
you know either the house or Senate and
quite a few that have passed both houses
both bodies have been signed into law
the state level I felt that that that it
really is the state's kind of limited
jurisdiction or limited purview to
protect us from the wrongdoing of others
to protect us from force and fraud to
protect us from
theft and other other types of crimes
and there was another argument that I
saw online that was made and that is
that there's a lot of fraudulent
material that's that's out there that's
being sold online where there's
absolutely no way to trace it back and
if people are buying
baby formula or food for their kids or
some such thing that there are a lot of
safety issues and people need to be able
to trace it back to an actual seller if
somebody's a large-scale seller it's uh
I've I've had to do this you know
similar type of work for my legislative
campaign just for you know online
advertising so I don't see that or even
sometimes even just to rent a car just
to put a car on the road so I don't feel
that it's an onerous burden and I feel
that the the need to protect the public
from fraud and from theft and the need
to protect our retail businesses small
and large is is big enough a concern
that I'm willing to
you know wave my regular
philosophy and say that that if people
are going to sell they need to they need
to be registered so we so that people do
have recourse
okay anybody else
see none so the motion by me is to not
recommend for future legislation
representative yes
representative boom yeah
clerk votes yes representative Evenson
no
representative ham yes
representative Doucet yes representative
McDonald yes representative Johnson yes
representative Terry yes representative
Bartlett yes
representative Herbert yeah
representative Van Houten yes
representative Weston yes
representative bill you no
representative Burroughs yes
representative McAleer yes
and chairman hunt yes 15-2 all right
and with that we're done
don't forget to fill out your mileage
mileage and you want these you want
these reports by when Mr chair uh
I mean I I have allocated my day
tomorrow to get this all done so 10 a.m
tomorrow morning okay
I don't have multi-written but they're
all here is the uh is Carrie going to be
typing Carrie is here yeah she is yeah
so I can give them to her and she can
type them out she could yeah I mean she
normally what they do is they send them
to me I preview and then send them on so
so if you just want to you know send
them to me then that's fine yeah
and how long are they generating four
sentences if that's too much
oh Mr chair